just she just put a hijab on. Yeah. What
that mean is it's not that the woman men
were not attracted. They just said, "Oh,
that looks like a religious woman." It
looks like the symbol she's given me is
she's not interested. Now, let me give
you an example, sister. If I was here
today in a police officer uniform and I
was standing here with my I look like a
soldier. Yeah. Okay. Imagine I'm a
soldier. You're going to come to me. If
somebody say you're going to say, "Help
me. Somebody's trying to I'm going to
say, "Sorry, just because I wear police
officer uniform doesn't mean I'm a
police officer." You're going to say,
"Well, you confuse me. Why are you
wearing a police officer uniform if
you're not if you're not a police
officer? Some woman come and say I wear
miniskirts but just because I wear
miniskirt and I look like women who do
bad stuff doesn't mean I do. But you're
wearing the uniform. So a man thinks
maybe she's like those women. So what
the uniform does is number one it
distinguishes you as a Muslim woman.
Play to
learn the meaning of the Quran. Bismi
in the name
[Music]
in the name bismi.
Wow. New word saved. Test yourself
Allah of
Allah. New combo. collect all the words
the most gracious
download now. The the reason why the
western world needs Islam. That's what
it says on this side. Yeah. The reason
why is because look, you're looking
you're looking at elderly. Yeah. They're
being thrown into care homes. Why?
Because we're living in a selfish
society. When you take God out the
picture and legislation out the picture,
everybody becomes individuals. They care
about their self. This becomes a dog eat
dog world. So what what happens with
sister? Is that what's your name? Zorya.
Sister Zoya. Okay. This is Zoya and
Diana. Yeah. And you've you've come to
Islam? Yes. Two years. Two years.
Alhamdulillah. Yeah. So, it started with
um well, I got across um Muhammad hijab
with Jordan Peterson. Oh, mah. Yeah.
Now, we don't like the Yeah. Yeah. For
obvious reasons, but uh yeah, that's
kind of started me to start researching.
So, so, so when you watch this video, is
that what led you to Islam? At the
beginning, it started me like it started
off like he made some points and I was
like, huh. And then I went on videos and
I was like, "Huh?" And then I saw go on
your videos and then you said, "Huh?"
Uhhuh. And then I went to check. Okay.
Fantastic. Huh. Okay. And then next
thing I know, I ordered a Quran at home.
My husband had no idea. Did you get the
guided prayer map? No. No. I was I just
ordered one completely. I was completely
disconnected. I just ordered one off
Amazon. Like a really pretty one. I just
saw Okay. We have it for free. We give
it for free. Thank you. Um, so I ordered
one. I read it, but I read it to
disprove it to my husband. I was trying
to basically do the opposite clown move.
I know. Your husband's a Muslim. Yeah,
my husband is a Muslim. Yes.
Alhamdulillah. So, uh I was trying to
disprove him. I know clown move but and
then I was like, "Oh my god, this is
it." You know, and then I it was very
funny actually. I was thinking I really
wanted to give my shahada to I was just
thinking it. I thought the day that one
day next he sends it was back then when
he wasn't coming to London all the time
and he was like, "Guess who I'm coming
to to the UK." And I was like, "Oh my
god." And I was like, "Okay." Okay. And
I did it in Birmingham. I was like I
traveled to Birmingham specifically to
meet him. Oh, you took your shahada with
him? Yes. Oh, wow. M. Okay. I think I
know. I think you may have shown me the
video. Yes, it was in Birmingham. There
was a big surp There was one video with
a big surprise. Was your husband there?
Yes, my husband was there. Was it
divided? No, it was another one. No, no,
no, no,
no. So, what's Okay. What's stopping you
from wearing the hijab? Stopping me.
Yeah. Why you not wearing like is it is
it a struggle or is it mommy's a bit?
It's a struggle. Oh, struggle. So, it's
not not cuz mommy's mom. It's She's part
of that story. Okay. So, I am What's
mommy's concern? What's mommy's concern?
Oh, she just doesn't like Islam in
general and doesn't like that whole
thing in general. I think No, I think
she's lovely. I think my think she's not
lovely. No, no. In a sense in the sense
No, no, of course not. Sorry. Sorry.
What I mean is I know when people have
hostility, you don't have hostility. Uh,
you misunderstood me. I'm I'm not
the real the real stuff, the real
religion and the Christianity they have
like There's a lot of similarities%.
Yeah, it's very similarity. Yeah. The
people that are following they're not
and the things that they imposing on
women and stuff and what she wants to do
now is 2,000 years later as I said. Oh,
okay. All right. I see you. Now, let me
tell you something. There's a book
called quite uh different beauty sick.
You need to get your mom to read that.
Yeah. Now, when you auntie when you say
she should choose what she should wear,
would you agree with that? I told her
I'm I told her that if she wants to wear
it, she can wear it. I'm just discussing
it why she is doing it. Good. And I
can't find the logic. Okay. Why? I'm not
telling her not to. I'm saying that I
can't see the logical reasoning behind
the logical reason. A part of the men
are not going to look at her. She's
going to attract attention. That's
that's at the bottom is going to that's
at the bottom that those women are being
stared at. Exactly. Exactly. There's
some men who find the kab is more
attractive than explain to me what is a
for women. Okay. Ara for woman is
basically her whole body except her
hands and her face. No. Yeah. Ara. Yeah.
Her a is everywhere. Aura is a different
definition. What we know is not energy.
It's something. Oh no no no no. Not
that. Not that. No no no no no. Sorry.
Sorry. Aura means um your parts of your
body that you can't show. For example,
as a man, my aura is from my belly
button to my knee. No no no. The ar
Yeah. Yeah. You're talking about
something else. You're talking about
Tell me about Ara that is like your show
or something. No, no, no. So basically
she knows a is like a as they know it
now in this society, right? Our
definition is different. No, like
energy. Oh. Oh. Like do you mean like an
energy? Yeah. She means it's like energy
that's that's around you. You told me
something not exactly. Not exactly
energy. It's basically it's something
that's like your aura. When your aura is
showing, it's something that it's like
we have
What is it like a is it like an energy?
Yeah, they like aura here. It's like an
energy that you give off. It's like an
energy that you have like you have big
aura, small, you know, like Okay. I
Okay, I don't know about the only we
know is that Okay. So, what I'm saying
is about men um all this kind of stuff.
This is not the main reason. The main
reason is very simple. Yeah. If you I
said this to your mom as well. If you go
to a doctor, when you go to a doctor,
the doctor prescribes you with medicine
and say take this this this and this.
You never question the doctor and say h
I don't trust you. Maybe you are trying
to kill me. Why? Because you trust he's
a doctor. He is graduated. He's has
certificates. Whatever it is, what he
gives you, you accept. Now we say God
has created us. Your heart is beating
because of God. You breathe because of
God. Your kidneys are functioning
because of God. You know your whole body
is a machine. When I look, I got a cut
here. Can you see this scar? Yes. Who
told my blood cells to come together?
Avatar. I I got you. So tell me about
things. So, so we say that's your
avatar. Good. Good. Okay. I I think I
know what you mean by that. Okay. So, we
call we don't call him avatar. We call
him God Almighty. Yeah. So, we say No,
no. God Almighty is something else. The
one that has created us. Avatar is your
body. Soul. No. Soul is your soul. Soul
is avatar. No. Avatar is your body. And
soul is your soul. Oh, okay. God is your
creator. Okay. Okay. So, my avatar body
slash there's cells there that
communicate and say he's bleeding. Help
him. Yes. The question shows what that
there is. You believe in God? Yes. Good.
So we say we trust God more than a
doctor, more than a pilot, more than a
taxi driver because he's the one who
gave me life. He's created me. So when
he says to me, when he says to me, Alli,
for example, you have to cover from your
navl to your knee. I'm like, it doesn't
make sense. Why? But my chest is
showing, my biceps are showing. What's
the point? I mean woman can be you can
say woman can be attracted to because
you have been told in the Quran and you
exactly can you that's why when he says
to me jump I say how high now when it
comes to wisdom sister says jump you
jump yes now but but but but stupidly no
of course not because God almighty will
never tell you to do something stupid
God will never say go to the there and
jump yeah but his words are 2,000 years
ago
1,500 and we have evidence why it's from
God though not blind faith. No, no, it's
okay. But uh I'm not saying it's not.
Yeah, it is. Yes. All religions are from
God. They are leading us. Not all. I
would say they have come from but
someone came to lead us towards Yes.
Prophets. Prophets. Yeah. Yes. So after
105 years 100 years later, so we're in a
society when the woman says no. If she
she has to be raped from someone, she
will be raped. Hijab has nothing to do
with we I know. Yes. So that's not going
to protect from from anyone looking for
anyone
anyone looking at her anyone.
No no no no anyone doing anything. The
Quran does not say that the hijab
protects you from rape. This is a big
misunderstanding. Exactly. What it does
protect protecting her because she she
can say no to a man. If he wants her
she'll say no I'm married. I'm sorry I
don't want you. So what exactly is doing
the the disturb? Let me tell you, let me
let me break it down. Number one, the
first thing is at the top, the the God
Almighty who created you is telling you
to wear it. That was Yeah. 1600 years
ago and even before that woman in
history have always wore the hijab. It's
the past 100
years. Yes. She's the next one. Yes. So
this is the main one. So after that for
example, yes, that's number one. That's
number one. And that means we need to
obey like your mom. She's your mom. She
might come and say to you, I have a bad
feeling about this friend. You might
think mom logically there's nothing
wrong with her. She says I know because
she has life experience. So you say my
mom said so she must know something.
That's the main reason. Now number two
nowhere in Islam does it tell you me I
as a man I'm an animal. You have to
cover yourself. This is not from Islam.
Islam says the following. Man and woman
have to do their job. For the men it
tells them on a micro level to a macro
level. Number one Islam doesn't sexually
objectify women. If you live in an
Islamic country you will never see naked
women around. Why? Because when men go
and see naked women, there was a study
done in America. They showed men woman
in bikini and they test they put wires
in his brain to see what part of the
brain lights up. They found the part of
the brain that lights for tool use. You
know, like screwdriver uh tools. The
part of the brain meaning when he was
looking at this woman in bikini, he did
not see her as human. The part of the
brain that lit up men, he saw her as an
inanimate object. Now, something to use.
Something to use. This doesn't mean
rape. This doesn't mean rape. Has to do
with her scarf. This No, no, no. Sister
Zoya Zoya. But the thing is that uh
Christians, they don't have that, right?
No, they do. No, no, no. Christians,
Christians. Christians have it. No, they
do. They do. They don't. No, no one is
doing it. No, but you know why? They
don't follow the religion. That's why.
But the Bible says if you don't cover
your hair, shave your hair off. To watch
the full discussion guys just click the
link here or in the description box
inshallah this will take you to my new
daer channel Ali Dawa Raw where from now
on all my da discussions will be aired.
Go now and subscribe now and enjoy this
video inshallah on that channel.